un dossier incompréhensible deux ans et
demi après les faits un viol sur une
enfant de 4 ans ce collectif féministe
dénonçons une impasse judiciaire on peut
pas rester devant ces faits en disant ah
c'est dommage
il n'y a pas eu suffisamment de
personnel pour traiter cette affaire
c'est pas possible
la société actuelle peut pas l'accepter
on est dans les dents la justice en
novembre 2016 à genlis et un instituteur
est mise en examen pour viols sur l'une
de ses élèves
rapidement les charges contre lui
s'effondrent mais la justice mais 18
mois a levé sa mise en examen
entre-temps des traces de sperme sont
retrouvés sur une culotte de la victime
l'adn identifié est celui de l'un des
membres de la famille l'enquète est
alors retiré des mains de la gendarmerie
ou des pistes possibles
c'est une certain personne qui aurait
commis des faits à proximité de la
famille or on sait aussi qu'un membre de
la famille et dans la gendarmerie et
donc pour éviter toute polémique
le juge d'instruction a souhaité confier
l'enquêté à la pj pour éviter toute
polémique
les associations croix la sphère relancé
en novembre dernier le père l'oncle et
le grand père de la victime sont placés
en garde à vue mais relâché sans mise en
examen six mois plus tard l'enquêté est
au point mort les associations demandent
des mesures urgentes pour protéger
l'enfant
la mise à l'écart de la famille qui pour
le moment nous la considérons comme
étant un danger
contacté le parquet n'a pas souhaité
s'exprimer et se range derrière l'avis
de l'aide sociale à l'enfance
l'an dernier elle n'avait pas demandé de
mesures particulières de protection